this man with the call Ron darling here
in our Honda Pilot sponsored inside a
report how are you Ron I I'm doing great
that was a great call by Jack Oregon's
imaginary Tony Walters he hasn't had a
hit a hit since September 10th and he
gets that hit the 13th only in baseball
you know what it really is only in
baseball it really really is I mentioned
that at the top of the the show Ron is
that we've seen you know crazy things
happen in the NFL playoffs like David
Tyree you know keeping his helmet on
with his football you know in the Super
Bowl I've seen and we've seen we've seen
NFL Super Bowl MVPs be guys that you
don't expect but baseball it's nothing
like it we're a guy like Tony Walters
who many people have never even heard of
who hardly gets hits let alone on the
road let alone a walk-off as the one
that wins the game it's unbelievable and
he gets double switched in you know as
an afterthought because he's always been
known as a very good athletic defensive
player and and he gets the big kid it's
just it's amazing you know that Jack
Corrigan could go straight to the
greatest city he's ever had in his life
because I don't know if he's ever had
another great hit and his wife right
before professional ball so what do you
think before we move on from this game
to the American League let's let's talk
about a couple of things what do you
think about that bear hug moment between
Baez and and our Erin Otto is that but
the most bizarre thing you've seen or
what it's one of the most bizarre things
I've ever seen I thought it was a little
ironic that Alex called it as the most
bizarre thing he's ever seen he's not
involved in a couple of those are things
with Bronson Arroyo so I thought that
was kind of ironic but I've never seen
anything like it but I will say as as
baseball has gone on and I think in many
ways I need a purse none of the ways so
much better but because of many reasons
those kind of things that would be
frowned upon when I played you know
baseball's more kind of a Country Club
kind of atmosphere you know the guys all
like each other they're like hanging out
with each other it's a more of a
gentlemanly sport now I'm sure it
wouldn't have
years ago but that that's that's alright
too
it's it's unique so anything unique is
always good so you're saying if somebody
did that with Howard Johnson he would
have gotten cold-cocked in 1986 no not
Howard Johnson Howard Johnson was a guy
he would have fit in perfectly now raid
night mighty cool so if somebody who
tried that with Ray Knight what would
happen rod well Eric Eric Davis tried it
in Cincinnati once and it was a right
cross and it found its mark Linux you
know we were on the Cincinnati turf for
about a half hour battling it out so
listen you don't want to see that either
yeah but the bear hug to me to me and
and I've completely shifted on this from
from a grouchy young man and now a more
civilized older man I think the bass
slaps the hug to me it was sportsman
like and I think young people that are
watched and will find it the same Ron
darling here and the Honda inside a
report so the the epitaph of the 2017
Chicago Cubs would read what ACOG Oh
Cubs would read what yeah required
season you know Friday of last week they
had the number one record in the
National League and as of last night
they're not in the postseason I think
that is one of the most remarkable bad
turnarounds you could ever have and it
just also goes to show how things can
change you know you go from buyers is
magical here to all the things that
happen positively how they battled
through some injuries and all those kind
of things and you know baseball's
endings are just so immediate that it
always catches you by surprise because
you always feel like you're going to get
it done so it's just unrequited a season
for them and but but you know the fact
quite a run and so how good are the
Rockies do you think I think the Rockies
are really good I think secondly they
have something you know very unique
and that is you know their home field is
unlike any of the other 29 ballparks in
baseball I think that the thing that's
been really hurting them all season
ended up being one of their strengths
last year they're both in but you know
marques Freeland they're the real deal
as far as pitchers starting pitchers are
concern and the Rockies to me with the
depth of their lineup if they can go on
one of those stretches where they start
out scoring people by vast numbers they
could also make a run to because they
have a unique kind of team and then
defensively which always is a big
concern in the postseason they're
probably one of the best defensive teams
in the game Ron darling
he's calling tonight's American League
wild card game from Yankee Stadium here
in the Honda inside a report on the Rich
Eisen show okay Ron we talked about it
throughout the year how the Tampa Bay
Rays seemed to adopt a philosophy that
was unique in starting a reliever and
then trying to either bring the starter
in in the middle of the game and had go
as long as you can or bullpen their way
through an entire game and now we're
seeing it in a playoff win or go home
baseball game tonight what do you think
of the A's decision to start Liam
Hendriks tonight well uh - I think it's
it's the right decision coming for their
ballclub because that's where their
strength is with a day off tomorrow if
they're able to get through this game
and also the strength of their club
happens to be their bullpen their
starting pitchers that they've either
been injured this year or taken off the
scrapheap
have done an amazing job but their
strength is their bullpen and I think in
one game or done scenario I think Bob
Nelson is making the great great move
their bullpen as opposed to opening I
know for most fans ain't no difference
but you know with the openers there's
always usually a starter who comes in
and heats up you know three and a third
innings for five innings but that's not
going to be the case tonight they would
love Hendricks to get one or two innings
but it's really strictly going to be a
Boca and there won't be any starters
that come into the game Etling Jackson's
on the roster but he's only there in
case we have a scenario like we saw last
night
Hendrix at the end the game for the
Chicago Cubs and if it has typical
scenario like that tonight then you
might see Edwin Jackson in extra innings
but this won't be there relievers and if
you work backwards
you got trying in for two you got
familias for - you got Rodney for one so
that's five right there at some point
you have to get four innings out of a
myriad of arms in that bullpen and it'll
be F to pop Melvin to try to make those
decision so what do you think the Yankee
strategy is tonight what do you think I
don't Aaron Boone is doing with this
with the the lineup that had the most
homeruns ever for a regular season yeah
Aaron offensively there's no strategy I
mean literally he has one team and you
know all-star quality just about at
every single position you know you have
a former MVP was going to be teaching
maybe one of the best players in the
game and right-field Aaron Hicks is one
under the later all years out of the
base year and do hard might be the
Rookie of the Year I mean you can go on
and on and on but that lineup
it's a lineup that's going to play 90%
of the time for Boone so I don't think
there's any matchups that he can do to
match what Melvin's going to do and that
is that none of the pictures other than
the guys at the end familiar and and
treinen are going to face hitters more
than once so what do you do if you're in
offense I I don't know I think well what
you have to consider if you're the
Yankee team this is the exact thing that
would happen if in the beginning of the
year or the middle of the year you
knocked out a starting pitcher in the
first inning and the opposite team had
the bullpen the rest of the game that's
how they have to consider it just that
kind of game except in that situation
though the team that says the pulp end
for the rest of the game is in a
situation they didn't want or expect
this is part of the a strategy I do you
think this is good for baseball well you
know I think he can only in the
postseason can be done in these kind of
wildcard scenarios where you have the
day off right afterwards
is it good for baseball I think what it
does as we saw with the temp that they
raised this year it allows teams that
might not have the depth of the Dodgers
of the Yankees and other teams to find a
fluid kind of ways to kind of try to
compete I think that's I don't know I
think I think that's a good thing but
don't forget Tampa Bay wouldn't have
been able to do what they did all season
if it weren't for Blake's no it's just a
corner right off you and zeroes you know
so right so you know you're just poor
and one out for some of these starters
here Ron you know as a former starting
pitcher I mean right I mean you guys
aren't totally useless anymore right I
yeah I I mean I I feel at times as as a
former starting pitcher that that's the
way it's going to go but you know
there's always those guys that transcend
any decisions that any analytic
Department is going to make you know
Christ no analytic Department is going
to take max scherzer out of a starting
rotation and for me you know and I I'm
old enough to care about this stuff I
always still look now probably on my on
my device but I always still look and
hope for the Mac pitching matchup since
I see a good one I always try to catch
it there so who from that Mets pen pen
would have been the best starter do you
think if Davey Johnson played this type
of ball oh geez I think I think I think
Roger McDowell was in that die because
he could easily get you to innings to
get the ball rolling with the maybe
force the other team got the left-handed
lineup and then at some point that
left-handed line across the face Jesse
Orosco for the final two innings ready
to go yeah a good mix and how would you
have taken the the the news that you're
in started but they were gonna bump on
their way to a championship trying I
would have bowled my neck in public
private I would have cried like a little
beige man this is this American League's
Jam too right I mean it just seems to me
that the the champ comes from the
American League Ron what do you think
yeah totally agree
you know I I think it's you know
Angela goes back and forth right I think
you know all these nationally teams at
some point they're gonna see what these
American League teams are doing and try
to match it I don't know how you match
some of its happenstance and walk what I
mean by that you know when you are the
Red Sox and you you know you draft and
you're looking for the best players
that's what every other team is doing
that but not everyone's going to end up
with bets and then attendee and Bogaerts
and Bradley jr. and on and on and on and
when you have these everyday young
starting players like Houston does like
Cleveland does like the Red Sox do and
also of the Yankees to a degree it you
know that's that's the way it was
thought of for a while but young
starting pitching was the way to go but
the fungibility of those injuries has
made that kind of not as attractive as
the everyday starting player who seems
to get injured last last one for you Ron
darling last night there was a replay at
second base
where Daniel Murphy flipped to second to
start a double play that ended the
inning and yet not a single player ran
off the field because they thought that
there was not an out at second base and
after further review
it was either upheld or it it was
confirmed
we have no idea because baseball does
not make the umpires do with the NFL and
the NHL does for in those refs
by explaining it to the crowd what why
do you think umpires either refused to
talk or Major League Baseball can't make
them talk to the crowd well I yeah well
I don't know what their collective
bargaining agreement is but what I think
should happen is that the crews should
took to get me put together and whether
it's the crew chief or not because not
everyone is comfortable talking to
50,000 people even if still one of the
best umpires but every every crew should
have one guy who has the ability to be
able to let the crowd know exactly what
happened on that play I think they
deserve it they pay a lot of money to
find out what's happening in these plays
and I think you know with all the
with all the new rules could kind of
convoluted the game and made it more
difficult not less difficult than and
and one of the ways that we could show
some love for the fans
he's just clue them in on what what the
heck's going on and I think that would
be much better all right Ron thanks for
the call let's chat down the line enjoy
that scene tonight it's going to be a
heck of a scene in the Bronx as always I
will read thank you all so proud thank
you always that's Ron darling of Turner
Sports a Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience